uh does it appear that we have the joker
he's ready to go he's put on the headset
after
his fifth triple double of the season
nicola yokic thank you very much for
joining us
or thanks for having me or should i call
you wilt
uh could a big man actually lead the
league and assist
for the first time since wilt how can
you can you stay on top of that category
i mean i don't know it's a long season i
think that does the how they play coach
coach coach put the ball in my hand a
lot and
i think i have a lot of opportunity to
to
make assists or make my my teammates
better
or give them easy easy points you know
it's it's not just me so it's a
strategy it's a teamwork so
if i can do it yeah why not you know
uh joker it's really weird i can't
imagine
trying to play basketball with kovic
going on
it was obviously totally different being
in the bubble
what is it like trying to live your
everyday life
uh you know i mean it's got i wouldn't
know how to handle it if i was a player
today
it's different you know it's a little
bit different but
those are the rules you need we need to
play by the rules uh
i mean i think the how the
all starts are happening uh the team who
is who is strict who is wearing the mask
who is
who have the more uh available players
are gonna are gonna have better records
i think that
they're just gonna one more opportunity
for
for teams to kind of have uh maybe some
some easy wins uh joker chuck and i just
watched you destroy little fella he
tried to play physical witcher you just
finessed him to death
when do you decide to play physical when
do you decide to say you know what
i'm not going to be physical at all i'ma
just kill this guy with finesse
like you did tonight i mean uh
i i didn't i i wouldn't say that i i
destroyed
him i think uh it depends i mean uh just
uh
i like to play slow i like to play to
see what's gonna happen on the floor
um are they going to double me where
they're going to come from i like just
um
i mean for for me and i think for for
teammates to beat every every every
game needs to be a learning experience
you know if they double our
from the baseline what we're going to do
with that if they double from the nail
what we're going to do i think it's just
uh
kind of wraps i mean they they double
mean
in you know in a playoff a lot so if we
can
have that we just need to kind of remind
ourselves you know and
sometimes when we need a bucket i just
need to go aggressive you know
not to score just to maybe get a foul
you know just have a
easy easy bucket uh
joker you know a lot of players we had a
debate about this at halftime there's a
lot of players that's in your position
that have the ball a lot in their hands
and sometimes it's to the detriment of
the team and then with you
it seems like it's been a positive for
you
how do how do you approach that knowing
that you're gonna have the ball
so many possessions so many positions
in so many areas how do one you stay
focused in it
keep your teammates locked in and not
tire yourself out over 72 games i think
it just
just me being uh up the floor a little
bit like to have the ball
on the top of the key it's it's better
because there's a lot of a lot of room
to
to cut a lot of room to to to go back
door
and dress if they make a good screen if
we
they need to respect you know uh
like good screen or empty space you know
they need to help so
i can get kick it out or i can i can i
can knock the mid-range so
it's just the game the game i never i
never go to the game like i'm gonna do
this this i'm always i always take
whatever game gives me
23 14 and 10 for big honey another
triple double
that's posibas thanks a lot for joining
us man
he's the wrong language again
we apologize he's not rushing about his
russian no he's not right
how was it growing up in moscow i'm not
from russia
you are a piece of work inside the nba
is next
come on stop come on stop being grasses
you look like drago to me from rocky
i thought he was rushing he looked like
dragon